I'm Neil hesitate I live and work at
Hilltop farm in Mullen I was born and
bred at Mullen I've always lived on the
farm the family have been here for over
a hundred years every day there's
something to do there's never a day
where there's not to do so it's a fairly
incessant work
you know you can't not go out because
it's really like snow in fact you know
on those days it's most important that
you're out there sort of making sure
things up something to eat and the way
they should be and they're not in any
danger from snow or wind or combination
of the two we do try to get ala days but
it's much more difficult because you've
always got to get people to to look
after the stock and the people you find
to cover you have to sort of have a bit
of knowledge as well in here there's
belted Galloway's but there's the brown
ones which are called done and then
there's the black and white ones and
obviously they've both got the
characteristics sort of belt around them
and hence the name these cattle are able
to live outside they're able to thrive
in these kind of conditions which most
cattle wouldn't be able to do live
outside all year round they live right
up on that skyline most of the year
there's three carbs so just come to
check on those check that they're all
doing okay but that there's one Cowlitz
whatever what's called the calf bed is
just it's just sticking out a little bit
so I've really just come to sort of
check that that's alright which and
allow the cows to exhibit as much of the
natural behavior as possible so you can
just see that the calf load in the in
the thistles and I have seen it opened
objected and it's obviously getting milk
off its mother
so we'll just go and leave her to do a
bit with it
it's a lot of work we mall with a sheep
Enterprise as always something to do
with the Sheep the time take not with a
sheep is the time that impacts the most
upon family life because you were
working extremely hard after spending a
lot of time with a sheet they can test
the patience somewhat I would never
discourage my daughter from going
farming despite it being hard work and
the bean days when you maybe don't want
to be doing it there's a lot of
positives in it as well and it's a great
life it's quite a nice feeling for me
knowing that you know my forefathers and
grandfather farmed this land and I'm
almost thinking that the way forward at
the moment is to go back to how things
were farmed a long time ago which which
seems odd in some respects but I think
we've got a farm in tune with nature and
we've got a farm in a way which doesn't
impact negatively upon the natural
environment around us so there's quite a
nice feeling about that but you know
that doesn't mean that I would put any
pressure on my daughter to to take it
over but if she wanted to that big
you
you